la medida que pasan las horas mayor es
la atención sobre lo que va a pasar con
esas 200 personas y un número indefinido
de militares que se encuentran atrapados
en esos túneles subterráneos de las
heridas o total que están siendo
atacados con mayor insistencia desde
ayer por las fuerzas rusas un grupo de
mujeres de los militares que se
encuentran allí atrapados van todos los
días a ese lugar donde llegan los
desplazados de la ciudad de saborit sea
llamar la atención por el futuro de los
militares natalia es una de ellas su
marido está atrapado allí y ella cree
que está herido hace días no tiene
contacto con él
sin esa seña ecuatoriana
el mensaje más potente que recibí de él
decía que nunca tuvo un deseo tan fuerte
de sobrevivir como hasta ahora por eso
están resistiendo agarrándose a la
mínima posibilidad de sobrevivir quieren
salvarse a toda costa se misión en
basilea ni me duda carla dudas más densa
caso saben que por eso quiero mandar mi
mensaje a los líderes de los gobiernos
para que nos ayuden a salvarnos y
sacarlos vivos
en qué condiciones
y juicio nihat uno
hoy se conocerá así esta misión de las
naciones unidas y de la cruz roja que va
camino a mariupol a rescatar al menos
esos 200 civiles especialmente mujeres y
niños que están allí atrapados tienen
éxito no es una misión fácil como no lo
fue la que sucedió esta semana donde al
menos 150 personas pudieron ser
evacuadas de allí el trayecto para
llegar hasta policía es bastante duro
como nos han contado muchísimos retenes
rusos muchísimos problemas así que los
ojos de los ucranianos están en lo que
pueda pasar en esa ciudad costera del
mar de azov de mariupol y con lo que
pasa con estas personas y militares que
están allí atrapados